exercice ou diverses espèces cette
profession je me dois devant vous de
compléter vos propos madame la
Présidente c'est une obligation
déontologique ainsi dans préciser les
contours
j'ai donc été embauché il y a 52 ans
par un laboratoire pharmaceutique
avioncib moratoire avelon qui d'ailleurs
n'existe plus comme salarié non cadre
pour exercer une fonction de délégué
médical à aucun moment je n'ai eu dans
ce laboratoire une fonction de direction
de gestion même d'animation cet emploi
qui a duré 5 ans
et qui a donc cessé il y a 47 ans m'a
permis de payer les études de mon
conjoint avant que je ne puisse
poursuivre à mon tour les miennes et
ainsi obtenir mon diplôme de docteur en
pharmacie tardivement
pharmacienne d'officine jusqu'en 1991 je
n'ai eu aucune fonction dans l'industrie
pharmaceutique depuis 47 ans vous avez
parlé de soggy farm je
veux préciser que cette fonction que
j'ai exercé a été dans le cadre d'une
action humanitaire en Guinée Conakry
où j'ai financé à mes frais petit
atelier de fabrication de
siropédiatriques de 1984 à 1991 cette
structure qui mobilisait quelques
bénévoles si ça sept peut difficilement
être présenté comme une multinationale
comme je l'ai vu dans quelques
publications malveillantes
non seulement elle ne m'a rapporté ni
rémunération ni bénéfice mais devant les
difficultés politiques et sociales de la
Guinée nous avons arrêté notre
implication et nous avons offert nos
installations les installations que nous
avions financées à nos amis guinéens
vous jugerez donc si j'ai pu à un moment
quelconque de mes activités d'élus ou de
ministres être impactés par un conflit
d'intérêt
j'ai donc eu l'honneur d'exercer la
fonction de ministre de la Santé du 18
mai 2007 au 13 novembre 2010 et j'ai
bien compris que c'est à ce titre que
vous m'entendez mon exercice a été
marqué par plusieurs défis qui
impactaient d'ailleurs la filière la
crise financière de 2008 la présidence
française de l'Union européenne ou
second semestre 2008 les travaux
intenses qui ont mené à la loi Bachelot
du 30 juillet 2009 appelé encore Hôpital
Patient Santé territoire la miss sur
pied des agences régionales de santé et
bien entendu
notre liste la gestion de la grippe A H1
la question du risque de pénurie ne nous
est pas apparu de pénurie de médicaments
ne nous est pas apparu anecdotique déjà
je pourrais me réfugier derrière des
chiffres victorieux mais peu
exploitables claironner qu'il n'y avait
que 89 épisodes de pénurie en 2010
et en quelques dizaines des années
précédentes il ne faut pas oublier que
les déclarations de pénurie n'étaient
pas obligatoire à l'époque et que ces
chiffres sont certainement sous déclarés
toutefois ces dysfonctionnements causant
des réactions fortes dans l'opinion
publique ils étaient surveillés par tous
les professionnels de santé et les
responsables publics
les difficultés concernent surtout des
traitements hospitaliers peu connus du
grand public tels des produits de
diagnostics le technestium 99 par
exemple ou des produits de
anticancéreux telle la chlore médecine
mais à terme la menace sur les officines
et la distribution des médicaments était
réels
en cause des problèmes de gestion des
stocks de la part des labos mais surtout
la réduction et la concentration
croissante des sources
d'approvisionnement dans les pays
émergents c'était le constat déjà dressé
par l'Académie nationale de pharmacie
qui avait réuni les autorités de santé
les industriels à ce sujet déjà
80% des principes actifs de médicaments
étaient fabriqués en Chine et Anne honte
et on Inde contrairement à peine d'1%
quelques années auparavant trentaine
d'années auparavant environ un millier
de producteurs indiens et chinois se
partagent ce secteur en plein essor en
2009 sur le marché mondial près de 60%
du chiffre d'affaires étaient généré
mondial était générée par des
industriels qui ne fabriquaient que la
matière active les labos occidentaux ne
prenant en charge que la formulation du
médicament
les spécialistes ajoutaient c'est
délocalisations se font pour des raisons
évidentes de coûts mais aussi sous la
pression des pouvoirs publics et en
promouvant l'utilisation des génériques
depuis une quinzaine d'années ont attiré
les acteurs indiens et chinois sur ce
marché des volumes et la Chine
concentrait à elle seule 40 à 50 % de la
production de principes actifs
génériques du marché européen relevait
le président de l'Académie nationale de
pharmacie Henry Philippe Husson à
l'époque avec à la clé le risque que
nous sont que nous connaissons de
dépendance acrue vis-à-vis des pays
producteurs mais aussi de risques sur la
qualité nous nous sommes donc dirigés
dans deux directions d'abord muscler
l'industrie pharmaceutique française
ensuite muscler la législation et donc
les obligations des différents acteurs
de la chaîne du médicament et je veux à
ce propos saluer l'engagement personnel
constant du président Nicolas Sarkozy
sur ce dossier
muscler l'industrie pharmaceutique de
notre pays
c'est ainsi que le 26 octobre 2009 a été
réuni le conseil stratégique des
industries de santé et à l'issue a été
pris un certain ensemble de décisions
qui répondaient à trois objectifs
majeurs développer les biotechnologies
au service des industries de santé
développer des partenariats entre
secteurs publics et secteur privé dans
la recherche biomédicale
accompagner les mutations industrielles
afin de préserver l'outil de production
c'est 11 mesures vous les trouverez bien
sûr sur le site internet je
vais pas aller les faire sauf si vous
souhaitiez ensuite m'entendre mais vous
les avez bien entendu
certainement dans vos dans vos dossiers
donc la passe sur ces 11 mesures
la seconde
consistait à prendre des mesures
réglementaires qui permettaient de
développer la communication enfin grand
public pour les médicaments de
médication officinale vous constaterez
qu'en ce domaine l'alternative domaine
de l'industrie pharmaceutique
l'alternative est simple faut-il
privilégier une politique de
relocalisation de produits et de
principes actifs matures donc une
industrie pharmaceutique d'entrée de
gamme
ou choisir la stratégie de l'excellence
et de l'innovation
et j'ai le sentiment que la question que
nous nous posions alors est resté
absolument pendant aujourd'hui
pour autant même si on privilégie la
stratégie de l'excellence et de
l'innovation il faut assurer l'accès à
ces produits matures est néanmoins
indispensable ce qui nous est apparu
relever d'une politique d'achat
diversifiée de stockage de précaution et
de systèmes d'alerte performant
il a donc été initié dès l'époque un
travail législatif de fond qu'elles se
sont attelées les services du ministère
de la Santé pour poser les outils
juridiques nécessaires et qui a trouvé
ensuite son véhicule dans la loi du 29
décembre 2011 dites loi Bertrand
dans le contexte du scandale du Médiator
auquel la loi voulait répondre on a
surtout retenu les éléments qui
concernaient ce scandale du Médiator
c'est-à-dire la prévention des conflits
d'intérêt le renforcement de la
pharmacovigilance et la création d'une
nouvelle agence du médicament l'Agence
française de sécurité sanitaire des
produits de santé était donc remplacés
par la NSM dont vous avez je crois
entendu récemment la responsable
cette loi on l'a un peu oubliée elle a
surtout contribué à renforcer le
dispositif réglementaire français de
prévention et de gestion des ruptures de
d'approvisionnement elle a en fait
transposé dans la loi un certain son
nombre de principes communautaires qui
préconisent de mettre en place des
obligations de service public pour le
titulaire de l'autorisation de mise sur
le marché comme pour les distributeurs
de médicaments c'est ainsi que cette loi
mais je sais que vous entendrez Monsieur
Bertrand mais c'est à la suite d'un long
processus législatif la loi étant de six
mois un an le délai d'information de la
NSM en cas de suspension d'arrêt de
commercialisation d'un médicament pour
lequel il n'existe pas d'alternative
thérapeutique sur le marché français
elle a mis en place un système
d'astreinte et des obligations de
services publics pour les grossistes
répartiteurs elle a prévu des sanctions
financières pour manquement aux
obligations des laboratoires exploitants
et des grossistes répartiteurs elle a
introduit pour la première fois une
définition de la rupture
d'approvisionnement dans la législation
et je parle bien
évidemment
du travail réglementaire qui a suivi
elle a introduit pour la première fois
une définition de la rupture donc
d'approvisionnement dans la législation
française en le définissant comme
l'incapacité pour une formation
d'officine ou une pharmacie à usage
intérieur de dispenser un médicament
impatient dans un délai de 72 heures et
donc c'est toi qui a été complétée par
le décret du 28 septembre 2012
à compléter le texte par nombre
d'obligations réglementaires obligations
pour les laboratoires exploitants pour
les grossistes répartiteurs et en fait
finalement pour toute la chaîne du
médicament et je dois dire que la loi
ensuite de Madame Touraine la loi du 26
janvier 2016 à utilement complété le
texte de la loi de décembre 2011 et du
décret de septembre 2012 puisque la
France grâce à cet ensemble
législatif la France a été le premier
pays à transformer à transposer
évidemment toutes ces dispositions
communautaires mais à former les
obligations réglementaires en obligation
légale et à introduire des sanctions
administratives et financières en cas de
manquement ces obligations donc vous
entendrez bien sûr
à la fois Monsieur Bertrand et Madame
Touraine mais ce travail législatif
a été commencé alors que effectivement
il n'y avait pas à proprement parler
d'alerte mais
j'allais dire l'environnement industriel
l'environnement mondialisation était là
et il ne nous avait pas échappé et nous
avons construit à la fois la stratégie
industrielle qui ne relevait pas du
ministère de la Santé je tiens à le
préciser le comité stratégique des
industries de santé
était impliqués à la fois madame Lagarde
ministre de l'Industrie accompagné son
ministre délégué Monsieur Estrosi Madame
la Ministre de la Recherche Valérie
Pécresse et moi-même ministre de la
santé mais la question de la gestion
industrielle du médicament relève plus
précisément de la responsabilité du
ministère de l'Industrie nous sert de la
santé évidemment
s'occupe de la l'aspect de la qualité du
médicament et de sa bonne dispensation à
tous les niveaux de la chaîne de la
chaîne pharmaceutique voilà mesdames les
ées natrices messieurs les sénateurs
madame la rapporteur madame la
Présidente ce que je pouvais dire un
point
qui m'apporte je suis donc auditionné
sur mes responsabilités
de 2007 à 2010
je ne souhaite pas m'exprimer je
témoigne sur ce qui concerne mes
fonctions de ministre de la Santé je
vais pas me livrer à l'ultra
crepidarianisme si vous me permettez et
faire car je n'en ai ni les moyens
d'investigation ni les responsabilités
de faire des commentaires sur la
situation actuelle de la crise des
pénuries
cela demanderait de ma part
d'être accompagné par qu'est-ce que
collaborateurs qui me ferait des notes
qui me transmettrai des rapports et des
dossiers
cordonnier pas plus haut que la
chaussure
je vous remercie madame la ministre je
donne immédiatement la parole à notre
rapporteur Laurence Cohen pour une
première série de questions
merci madame la ministre je vais essayer
de rester dans une fonction passer mais
ça peut un peu empiéter quand même vous
jugerez dans par vos réponses votre
votre
tout à fait mais bon j'ai déjà eu
l'occasion d'assister à vos auditions
dans le cadre des commissions d'enquêtes
donc j'ai pas j'ai pas de doute en tant
que ministre de la Santé à l'époque et
la présidente d'ailleurs la souligner
vous avez dû
gérer l'épisode H1 qui a fait coller
beaucoup d'encre et vous avez me
semble-t-il été guidés juste titre par
un principe de prévention et de
précaution maximale
et la question que j'ai envie de de vous
poser c'est est-ce que ça ne
suppose pas de sortir pour partir les
médicaments qui comme chacun sait ne
sont pas des des biens comme les autres
sortir donc les médicaments des logiques
de rentabilité et du marché en
envisageant le retour à une véritable
production publique en partie et
notamment pour les médicaments critiques
là où aujourd'hui il semblerait que le
secteur concurrentiel soit quelque peu
défaillant c'est ma première question ma
deuxième question c'est toujours au
moment où vous gérez donc cette pandémie
vous aviez été accusé
vous vous en souvenez d'en faire trop
et du coup par la suite il y a eu des
politiques publiques de stockage des
produits qui ont été différentes ou pas
différentes d'ailleurs mais nous au
niveau en tant que législateur nous
sommes confrontés à ces questions de
durée de stockage où on parle de deux
mois de 4 mois etc il y a toute une
polémique là-dessus ce qui me semble pas
obligatoirement le fond le fond de la
question mais vous qui avez été donc au
cœur des décisions où est-ce que vous
pensez
utile nécessaire indispensable de placer
ce curseur sachant effectivement que le
coût du stockage est loin d'être d'être
négligeable donc on peut pas faire
n'importe quoi ma troisième question
c'est sur la gouvernance et le pilotage
de l'ensemble du système qui a été mis
en place et on a été alerté lors de
plusieurs sur un peu j'allais dire le
chevauchement des différentes agences
qui sont en France multiples vous avez
vous-même été à l'origine de la création
des ARS donc c'est un échelon au niveau
au niveau régional mais est-ce que vous
pensez que toutes ces agences finalement
sont un gage de transparence
de bonnes diffusion des informations
notamment aux patients mais également
professionnels de santé je pense aux
pharmaciens mais je pense également au
médecin et est-ce que vous pensez qu'un
comité de pilotage à dock chargé de la
stratégie de prévention et de lutte
contre les pénuries de médicaments est
une bonne solution
autre question c'est que le gouvernement
a annoncé d'ici la fin du mois
l'établissement d'une liste de
médicaments critiques beaucoup plus
restreinte que celle des ITM nous avons
été confrontés avec la présidente lors
de plusieurs de nos déplacements
de dire confrontation de ces différentes
listes chacun chaque organisme au niveau
européen au niveau national par de
l'établissement de liste et
nous nous semble à l'étape actuel de nos
auditions qu'effectivement cette liste
serait bienvenu mais qu'il faudrait la
restreindre parce que sinon elle
n'aurait plus d'efficacité est-ce que au
moment où vous étiez ministre de la
Santé vous étiez déjà
alerté préoccupé vous aviez déjà
travaillé sur les laboration d'une telle
liste
l'autre question que je voudrais vous
poser c'est sur le prix du médicament
est-ce que
vous pensez que le prix du médicament
dont on a vu notamment que les
médicaments matures étaient plutôt tirés
on va dire vers le bas et c'est un
reproche qui qui a été fait donc est-ce
que cette cet état de fait peut
compromettre l'approvisionnement du
marché français
ou peut-il inclure une part de
sécurisation des approvisionnements de
soutien de l'industrie et en particulier
à la réimplantation de la production de
certains principes actifs sur le
territoire national parce que vous
l'avez noté déjà à votre époque et bien
il y avait 80% des principes actifs qui
étaient déjà en Chine et en Inde et
c'est toujours toujours le cas
aujourd'hui
vous avez eu la particularité la
particularité d'avoir été il me semble
que c'est unique peut-être que je me
trompe au cours de votre carrière non
seulement ministre de la de la santé
mais vous avez été également ministre de
l'écologie et du développement durable
donc c'est à ma connaissance je crois
pas qu'il y a eu d'autres ministres qui
est cette charge-là et pourquoi je vous
positionne cette question
mais la question que je veux vous poser
pourquoi je parle de je parle de
l'écologie je sais aussi que vous avez
été plus récemment ministre de la
Culture mais au niveau de l'écologie
c'est parce que effectivement
l'industrie chimique est une industrie
qui est particulièrement
polluante et donc je voulais savoir quel
était votre votre regard évidemment avec
le fait que si on relocalise en France
et bien il y a d'ailleurs même en
délocalisant il faudrait avoir la même
préoccupation parce que c'est une
préoccupation calme mais en tout cas
avoir des exigences de normes
environnementales
importantes et qu'est-ce que vous en
pensez de votre point de vue de ministre
enfin ma toute dernière question ça
concerne
les industries pharmaceutiques
qui donc ont reçoivent des aides au
niveau du cire pour la recherche et le
développement et quand vous aviez été
ministre de la Santé vous aviez décidé
de supprimer le plafond
du cire de 16 millions d'euros pour le
remplacer par un montant égal à 30% des
dépenses de R&D en dessous de 100
millions puis 5% au-delà et est-ce que
cette décision qui a donc été profitable
pour les industries pharmaceutiques et
qui auraient dû leur permettre donc
d'avoir une une politique performante en
matière d'innovation de recherche etc
est-ce que ça vous a paru efficace et
quels ont été les raisons qui vous ont
guidés
à cette époque et est-ce que vous vous
pensez que les résultats ont été à la
hauteur de l'investissement voilà c'est
des questions qui sont multiples et
variées donc je vous remercie par avance
des réponses que vous allez pouvoir
apporter
madame la ministre
madame la rapporteur je vous remercie
pour cette batterie de questions
j'espère que
vous me rappellerez alors si j'oublie
quelque chose
merci finalement d'avoir salué ma
gestion de la grippe à Shanna et d'avoir
indiqué que dans le domaine de la santé
et les principes de prévention et de
précaution doivent l'emporter sur tout
autre considération économique
et j'ai trouvé d'ailleurs tout à fait
intéressant qu'à l'époque j'ai été
accusé d'avoir manié ses principes
mais je pensais qu'on me rendrait
justice après ma mort j'ai il laisse
latence satisfaction de voir que
celle-là était avant très bien
et que nous avons pas obéi au logique de
marché
vous indiquez très justement
l'embrouille à mini
de des institutions qui s'activent dans
le domaine de la santé donc du
médicament
et qui ont d'ailleurs développé un
certain nombre de partenariats dans
cette alliance nationale pour les
sciences de la vie et de la santé
effectivement
l'insert le CNRS le CEA l'INRA
l'Institut Pasteur
l'IRD la conférence du président
université la Conférence des directeurs
généraux CHU mais ils ont ma foi chacun
leur utilité l'essentiel est qu'il
travaille ensemble
rajouter un comité
supplémentaire ça c'est une chose bien
française motive de simplifier on
rajoute un formulaire et un organisme ça
alors là on y dérogera pas je prédis que
vos travaux aboutiront à ça c'est-à-dire
un petit peu plus de complexité et un
organisme
supplémentaire parce qu'évidemment tous
ces gens ayant une utilité majeure on ne
les supprimera pas et d'ailleurs bien
entendu le gouvernement qui se risquera
à supprimer
ces acteurs sera accusés des pires
crimes
les agences régionales de santé au moins
ont répondu à ce désir de simplifier à
cette volonté de simplification car
n'oublions pas qu'elles ont remplacées
par moins de 7 organismes pour les
remettre dans la main de ces agences
régionales de santé
quelquefois ça m'amuse parce qu'on parle
des dates et des draps et je dis mais
vous savez que j'ai supprimé les dates
et les grâces ah bon c'est incroyable
comme il n'y a pas eu une seule journée
de grève dans cette affaire évidemment
tout ça est passé inaperçu parce que
pour qu'il y ait une bonne réforme elle
se juge au nombre de personnes qu'on met
dans l'arche il n'y a aucune allusion
avec ce qui est en train de se passer
dans l'actualité bien entendu
bien sûr
je suis incapable de la moindre
malveillant
nos ARS ont quand même
subit un choc évidemment tout à fait
dommageable de la désastreuse
réforme territoriale des grandes régions
sur une administration
adolescente et même moins qu'adolescente
cela a été un véritable coup de poignard
que ces grandes régions mais ça c'est
une note de bas de page
en tout cas
les ARS exercent des fonctions puisque
l'inspection de la pharmacie peut se
faire à la fois par les pharmaciens
inspecteurs de santé publique et
également par les pharmaciens inspecteur
des ARS
vous
abordez une question très importante sur
le fait que l'industrie pharmaceutique
n'est pas une industrie comme les autres
c'est
des dernières industries de notre pays
qui soit avec des prises administrées et
la question se pose dans cette
environnement mondialisé faut-il
finalement créer une industrie d'État
ou est attisée
pourquoi pas
je dois dire que j'ai pas une très très
grande confiance dans l'état pour mener
ce genre de
d'opération
mais pourquoi pas à condition évidemment
de profondément réformé
un ensemble de législations et de ce
tamponner avec des législations
européennes
parce que il faudra équitivement
revenir sur en particulier
les questions de marché
d'appel d'offres
à partir du moment où on fera une
industrie d'État les prix des
médicaments n'auront rien à voir avec
les prix des spécialités telles qu'ils
nous sont proposées par
les industries des pays émergents
dont on en connaît les
tarifs les salaires
les conditions sociales et vous avez
raison de parler de l'écologie
bien entendu avec des normes écologiques
moindres et le fait qu'on est bien
content aussi dans cette industrie
pharmaceutique qui est une industrie
chimique on l'oublie mais une industrie
polluante donc on est bien content
d'exporter nos nuisances et de les faire
assumer par des pays en développement
donc pourquoi pas une industrie d'État
est-ce qu'elle serait d'ailleurs à même
de pallier à 100% les problèmes de
pénurie sans doute non car quand on
regarde les raisons des pénuries sont
pas toujours liés à la fabrication au
fait que la fabrication soit
externalisée il peut y avoir même dans
des industries autochtones
des ruptures de stock des difficultés
dans la chaîne de fabrication des grèves
des occupations et toutes sortes d'aléas
qui peuvent impacter la distribution des
médicaments
donc je suis
attentive à cette solution
mais
je me méfie beaucoup des solutions très
simpliste
en tout cas quand j'ai été ministre de
la Santé et dans le cadre du comité
stratégique des industries de santé ce
n'est pas la voix qui a été choisie
délibérément et à l'évidence et la choix
d'excellence c'est le choix d'excellence
et d'innovation qui a été choisie
selon les bons vieux principes de
Monsieur Ricardo des avantages
compétitifs
et nous avons choisi au contraire de
penser que la sécurité de
l'approvisionnement était plutôt liée à
l'Arsenal
législatives et réglementaires et à des
structures de veille
sur le marché sur le marché mondialisé
effectivement le prix du médicament est
dans notre pays et tout à fait important
nous avons choisi
les gouvernements de gauche et de droite
de considérer le prix du médicament
comme le variable d'ajustement dans les
comptes de la Sécurité sociale pour
diminuer les dépenses
on est abouti on a abouti ainsi à ce que
actuellement je parle en grande masse
50% des spécialités pharmaceutiques
françaises
sont les moins chers du marché européen
et que 92% des spécialités
pharmaceutiques françaises
ont un prix inférieur au prix moyen des
5 grands pays européens la France
l'Allemagne le Royaume-Uni l'Espagne
l'Italie qui constituent le gros du
marché pharmaceutique
ce n'est pas sans inconvénient puisque
évidemment les détenteurs de stocks de
ces produits peuvent à tout moment être
tentés de les distribuer dans des pays
qui ont
appris de vente plus intéressants
connaît par exemple l'exemple de
l'amoxicilline dont la forme injectable
est à peu près deux fois plus cher en
Allemagne qu'en France
et ce marché parallèle dont vous avez
certainement entendu les différents
des différents acteurs c'est quand même
5 milliards de chiffre d'affaires
donc
on a choisi une politique d'écrasement
des prix dont on peut penser qu'elle
n'est pas sans impact sur les
approvisionnements même si ce n'est pas
sans doute l'aspect principal des des
ruptures que nous enregistrons
alors vous
m'interpeller sur les modifications qui
ont eu lieu sur les rémunérations et les
aides à porter au laboratoire c'est pas
le ministère de la Santé qui gère cette
affaire là c'est
les aides aux industriels ont relevé du
ministère de
l'économie et de l'industrie et de la
recherche
le ministère de la Santé est plutôt
je dirais un spectateur engagé
est-ce que c'est
ces aides ont eu l'impact attendu vous
savez j'ai quitté le ministère de la
Santé en 2010
il m'est bien compliqué de vous répondre
je n'ai pas les éléments techniques qui
me permettent de
le dire vous savez la fonction
ministérielle implique concours dans son
couloir
et d'ailleurs ce qui ce risque a posé à
un pied hors de ce couloir se font en
général sévèrement rappelé alors donc
c'est plutôt madame le rapporteur à vous
de fixer si ces politiques initiées par
le ministère de l'Économie et de
l'industrie ont eu une efficacité
en tout cas
et si je peux à ce niveau exprimer un
regret je le répète parce que je l'ai
déjà exprimé dans d'autres enceintes
c'est que la liquidation de les Prusse
m'a paru une mauvaise décision
et que
à l'évidence
je vais justement
infirmer ce que je viens de dire et
faire un pas de côté mais comme je suis
déjà exprimé sur cette affaire la fusion
de l'épouse dans santé publique France
m'a paru une mauvaise décision et la
reconstitution d'un établissement de
réserve
et d'urgence sanitaire me paraîtrait
une bonne décision
vous voyez que je suis prête à renoncer
tout moment à mes principes
deux questions sur les stocks et sur la
liste est-ce que vous avez été la liste
bien
à l'époque nous avions estimé qu'il y
avait une liste de médicaments essentiel
qui était celle de l'OMS et que rajouter
des listes aux listes c'est plutôt
embrouillé les choses que de les
clarifier
merci beaucoup madame est-ce que les
collègues ont
ont une question
Emilienne
oui merci madame le ministre je voulais
revenir un petit peu sur juste sur le
sujet de l'étatisation
[Musique]
oui je voulais revenir sur le sujet de
l'étatisation parce que la façon dont
vous avez répondu semblait vouloir dire
que on pouvait envisager une
métatisation de l'ensemble de
l'industrie pharmaceutique ce qui a
l'évidence
même pas en rêve allez se dire quelque
chose de de possible
donc est-ce qu'il y aurait
la possibilité d'envisager pour certains
médicaments qui seraient donc dans cette
fameuse liste qui doit être établie qui
sera peut-être la énième liste
effectivement mais en tout cas dans ton
espère que ce sera plus restreinte que
celle des MITM est-ce qu'il y aurait la
possibilité de dire qu'on
réindustrialise peut-être pas en France
européenne de façon publique ou en V
comme partenariat public privé comme on
le voit dans certains pays est-ce que ça
vous pourrez apparaître une solution
envisageable
moi je voudrais pas avoir été mal
compris j'ai jamais promené les
tatisations de l'industrie
pharmaceutique c'est peut-être comme on
dit comme on dit en anglais pas il va
être chaud
j'avais dit que ceux qui pensent que
c'est une solution
faisable et qui rêve d'un grand service
industriel de l'industrie pharmaceutique
je pense s'égare je voudrais être
parfaitement clair et je pense que c'est
pas le rôle de l'État de de faire de
faire cela il peut aider par des
politiques d'appui industriels des
laboratoires qui voudraient tenter cette
expérience de relocalisation il y a
d'ailleurs des projets et même des
choses qui sont en train de se
concrétiser
j'appelle l'attention sur le fait que si
ce n'est pas accompagné par la révision
des règles de marché public c'est
laboratoires sont condamnés déposer très
rapidement la clé sous la porte parce
qu'effectivement les prix étant
absolument pas ceux qui sont les les
prix de ces spécialités matures
ils seront retoquer au niveau des au
niveau des règles des marchés publics
c'est d'ailleurs ce qui est déjà arrivé
à certains laboratoires qui se sont
risqués assez cette affaire et qui se
sont vu recaler donc très bien alors
faire une industrie européenne
pourquoi pas mais les mêmes choses
produiront les mêmes effets vous savez
il y a une phrase de Bossuet
que j'aime beaucoup et qui s'applique
vraiment notre dossier
Dieu se rit des hommes qui se plaignent
des conséquences dont il chérissent les
causes
des questions complémentaires madame la
ministre vous avez évoqué les politiques
d'achat diversifiés notamment dans les
appels d'offres hospitaliers que vous
aviez regardé avec attention vous étiez
ministre il semblerait c'est pas il
semblerait d'ailleurs d'abord un les
pénuries se sont très largement aggravés
et donc ce qui avait été
ce qui avait débuté quelques années
avant vos fonctions ministérielles a
pris un tour complètement
dramatique finalement quelque part
et ses achats diversifiés ils commencent
tout juste à se mettre complètement en
place au niveau hospitalier auront sait
que la pénurie hospitalière de de
médicaments est un vrai sujet et en
matière de coût pour la santé on voit
très bien que on est bien loin des
objectifs d'économie attendus dans le
PLFSS donc ça c'est mon premier ma
première question c'est à l'époque où
vous aviez commencé à envisager ce sujet
comment vous expliquer le fait que ça
soit pas mis pas mis en place et
vous étiez ministre en charge des
hôpitaux aussi donc il y avait même
la conférence
là je suis évidemment je suis est-ce que
ça signifie que tous les outils en tout
cas réglementaire
du régime des intermittents du spectacle
je vais être beaucoup plus capable de
répondre
sur ce sujet et en revanche est-ce que
ça signifie que finalement la
réglementation mise en place à l'époque
était pas assez invasive et
et
n'a pas permis que les choses se
structurent ma deuxième question porte
sur sur le rôle les distributeurs et des
grossistes répartiteurs puisque c'était
c'est un système qui est instauré en
France depuis fort longtemps et
d'ailleurs
comme vous avez géré une pharmacie vous
voyez tout à fait comment les choses
fonctionnent quelle est la part jouer
par par cette par les grossistes
répartiteurs dans ce système du
médicament et de dispensation du
médicament et de distribution dans les
territoires
ma troisième question va porter
justement sur les ARS qui ont remplacé
les bases traces et puis d'autres
d'autres structures un des atouts des
dates c'était d'avoir des inspecteurs
sur les terrains et
des personnes formées pour la veille à
une échelle territoriale semble-t-il
d'ailleurs ça a été confirmé depuis
l'échelle départementale qui avait un
intérêt
et donc
est-ce que vous ne pensez pas finalement
que cette veille allait au niveau de la
NSM donc nationale avec une absence de
va-et-vient et de surveillance
territorialisé de la pénurie de
médicaments est un défaut dans le dans
le système et pensez-vous que les ARS
pourraient se structurer pour jouer ce
rôle là de veille et d'aller et retour
entre les professionnels de santé que ce
soit pharmacien ou prescripteur sur le
terrain puisque on voit bien aussi que
la gestion de pénurie sur les terrains à
un coût aussi en matière de dépenses en
matière de de dépenses de santé
et puis ma
dernière question va porter
effectivement sur les stocks donc vous
dites reconstituer un établissement
d'urgence et de réserve sanitaire on
voit bien que ces dernières années tout
est allé dans le sens contraire de la
gestion de stock qui dit stockey share
c'est le first in first out de
l'industrie qu'on a appliqué à la santé
et aux médicaments
et
on voit bien que ce sujet est important
et toutes les structures finalement
publiques et parapublique qui étaient en
charge du médicament
que ce soit la GEPS par exemple ou que
ce soit les Prusse ont disparu ou à
moins de riz de façon très drastique
finalement leurs compétences et leurs
capacité à faire et donc je reviens sur
cette question finalement d'une sphère
publique qui serait en situation de ou
en capacité de en matière de
en matière d'urgence de pénurie enfin de
crise de pénurie et même si
effectivement vous vous dites que les
retours d'expérience et les plans et la
planification tout ça n'est pas
forcément positif il n'empêche que avoir
une planification minimale en cas de en
cas de pénurie de médicaments il
semblerait que ce soit quand même
quelque chose à mettre en place en tout
cas pour enrayer cette espèce de
dégringolade de de la disponibilité de
médicaments et puis ma dernière question
porte sur les la typologie des
médicaments la nouveauté c'est que on
est sur on a des anticancéreux en
pénurie la nouveauté c'est que les
formes pédiatriques sont
particulièrement
défaillantes sur le marché et et à
disposition notamment les formats à
destination des nourrissons
et qu'elle regarde vous portez sur ce
sujet parce que finalement c'est sur ces
sujets là maintenant que les choses se
cristallisent
d'abord moi je veux saluer
la qualification pharmaceutique de
l'ensemble du système
du médicament dans notre pays
ce sont les pharmaciens qui à tous les
niveaux
de la fabrication
de la distribution
de la dispensation du médicament
sont à l'œuvre
et je dois dire que
remettre en cause pour une raison
quelconque ce système de haute
qualification de haute qualité de
l'ensemble du circuit pharmaceutique
me paraîtrait une régression
est-ce que le système législatif peut
être améliorée durci
pourquoi pas
je dois dire que
[Musique]
il a été mis en place un système
d'astreinte et d'obligation de services
publics pour les grossistes répartiteurs
ces derniers sont tenus d'assurer
l'approvisionnement continue du marché
national pour couvrir les besoins des
patients avec des dispositions
réglementaires strictes
les sanctions financières pour
manquement aux obligations à la fois des
laboratoires exploitants et des
grossistes répartiteurs
il a été défini pour la première fois à
l'époque une définition de la rupture
d'approvisionnement dans la législation
française en le définissant comme
l'incapacité pour une pharmacie
d'officine ou une formation à usage
intérieur de dispenser un médicament
dans un patient dans un délai de 72
heures cette armature il convient de la
faire respecter on peut toujours
durcir ces conditions pourquoi pas
ça demanderait une analyse que je n'ai
pas les moyens techniques de faire ici
devant vous pas quelque chose qu'on
décide à tient Coucou On va porter cette
affaire
au lieu de la mettre à trois jours à 4
jours
des études d'impact à faire et amener
de façon sérieuse et en y impliquant le
maximum de partenaires à tous les
niveaux de la chaîne
vous m'excuserez donc de ne pas répondre
comme ça de chic c'est pas parce que je
travaille dans une chaîne d'info que je
dois parler de ce que je ne connais pas
bien entendu
je ne suis pas une toute loge
vous avez continué madame la Présidente
sur pardon ma mémoire me fait défaut
sur le
sur les autorisations sur la distribue
en fait c'était sur la distribution sur
les achats diversifiés dans les hôpitaux
qui se viennent juste tout juste de se
mettre en place donc venez d'y répondre
directement et si je comprends pas les
compétences pour répondre si je
comprends bien en creux c'est quand même
plutôt la chaîne de contrôle et de
surveillance et de mise en oeuvre de la
réglementation finalement qui mériterait
peut-être d'être renforcé puisque la
réglementation d'abord moi je suis comme
me disent mais les directeurs
les directeurs généraux des ARS je suis
la maman des ARS c'est à dire comme ça
qui ne va pas
ils ont même compensé une chanson
je pense que les ARS sont un outil
extraordinaire de santé publique
ils ont été
sottement critiqués au moment de la
crise du covid alors qu'ils ont rendu
des services éminents
que il y a dans ces agences régionales
de santé des agents qui se sont vraiment
défoncés la paillasse jour et nuit pour
gérer cette crise
et que vraiment il y a certaines
critiques qui m'ont
mis en rage
que
ces ARS et ensuite servi de variables
d'ajustement à certaines réductions
d'agents tout le monde le sait
alors que les fonctions qu'on leur
demande sont de plus en plus complexes
et de plus en plus exigeante
et le scandale d'orpa est venu nous
rappeler
d'Orpea et d'autres systèmes rajouter
ce qu'on vient d'entendre sur les
crèches
donc il s'agit vraiment de muscler ces
agences régionales de santé
de faire en sorte que les structures
départementales surtout avec cette
absolument désastreuse réforme
territoriale
ces structures départementales rendent
tout à fait indispensable
et
je ne peux que constater mais là je suis
un petit peu comme le pas trop bas du
Parthénon
je n'ai pas les éléments techniques
documenté et argumenté qui me
permettrait de dire voilà ce qui manque
exactement mais ça vous allez le faire
j'espère que sera enfin rendu justice
aux agences régionales de santé
merci la question c'était celle-là
effectivement d'une vision
territorialisée de de l'action publique
et la pénurie de médicaments fait partie
de la gestion que dans les territoires
et que le journal de santé l'information
doit passer il y a donc cette notion de
de veille avec un circuit à la fois
ascendant et descendant qui implique la
NSM les ARS et l'ensemble des
organisations professionnelles et tout
cela doit circuler de la meilleure façon
très bien je me suis est-ce que
des questions parmi mes collègues madame
la rapporteur
S
donc comme ça non mais évidemment
j'avais une question mais j'ai peur que
la ministre me réponde pas parce que
c'est sur de la prospective et sur le
fond même de
notre système et vous l'avez dit des
prix administrés des prix de revient qui
sont pas équivalents quand il y a des et
et
Bercy calamas sur sur le ministère de la
Santé donc à partir de là je crains
qu'il n'est la main pas seulement dans
le ministère de l'essence
je veux partager mais comme nous sommes
sur un sujet de santé mais notamment
évidemment il a la main sur tout et sur
le ministère de la Santé et qu'à partir
de là
poser une question mais
comment va sortir de ce système là
la sécurité sociale est un
quelque chose évidemment de merveilleux
mais on a fait peser beaucoup sur le
médicament et je le dis avec beaucoup de
précaution parce que je suis encore en
exercice donc mais compte tenu de ce
schéma là
si éventuellement vous aviez une vision
des choses est-ce qu'on peut espérer que
les choses évoluent est-ce que est-ce
que c'est au niveau européen j'en suis
pas certaine alors sur la production oui
mais après quick des prix comment un
médicament
produit
européen avec des une entente européenne
comment on arrivera à expliquer qui vaut
temps qui peut se vendre en France et et
étant en Allemagne enfin j'avoue que
j'arrive pas à tant qu'on aura cet outil
merveilleux de protection sociale que la
sécurité sociale et qui donc englobe la
branche maladie et la prise en charge le
nombre médicaments avec des prémics
comment on peut on peut on peut voir un
avenir meilleur en termes de
je crois que vous ouvrez en cette fin
d'audition
le sujet de l'Europe et de l'Union
européenne et je pense que évidemment
dans vos travaux vous ne vous
dispenserez pas de cette réflexion parce
qu'il y a une sorte de paradoxe
puisque
les politiques sociales et les
politiques sanitaires ne font pas partie
du paquet
communautaire mais en même temps on
imagine bien que il est difficile de
s'en abstraire et que d'ailleurs
la loi du 29 décembre 2011 a transposé
des dispositions qui sont des
préconisations des recommandations plus
que des dispositions législatives
européennes
mais que dans ce marché
européen on voit bien que si on mène une
politique industrielle strictement
franco-française on va très vite taper
dans le mur mais comment justement gérer
ce paradoxe que nous avons soulevé
ensemble de politique sanitaire et de
normes sanitaires qui sont très
différentes devant les pays dans les
pays
du fait que le prix des médicaments
n'est absolument pas le même que les
pratiques de prise en charge ne sont pas
les mêmes la France est à travers le
prix
les remboursements par la Sécurité
Sociale et par les organismes
complémentaires qui ne marchent en fait
que par les aides aussi qui sont un
système paras est attisé arrive à un
taux de prise en charge solidaire qui
est le plus élevé d'Europe bon
donc tout ça c'est une sorte de pièce de
puzzle qu'on essaie de faire rentrer
dans le trou qui ne convient pas
donc je vous soulevez quelque chose et
je ne vois pas actuellement la porte de
sortie puisque on essaie dans cette
affaire beaucoup plus de préserver les
acquis communautaires que d'en créer
d'autres dans un mouvement de défiance
généralisée vis-à-vis des institutions
européennes
et vous avez même dans ce cadre soulevé
la question de l'écologie et des normes
écologiques
donc je suis perplexe et je vous
remercie d'avoir créé cette commission
d'enquête et peut-être justement de
d'apporter des outils prospectifs au
gouvernant pour tracer tracer certains
chemins qui ne nous permettrait de
sortir de ces paradoxes sinon de ses
aporis
donc j'ai une nouvelle question donc
je refais le tour c'est la dernière j'ai
l'impression madame
il n'y en a plus que pour une minute
avec la roulette et ça continue
pas le l'action
de la roulette et Madame
c'est juste ce qui nous ce qui nous
guide et Madame la rapporteur voudrait
juste rebondir sur sur votre
intervention et après nous arrêterons
merci la présidente merci madame la
ministre c'est en vous écoutant
finalement que la question m'est venue
vous avez exprimé que le taux de prise
en charge solidaire en France et le plus
élevé d'Europe justement les coûts vous
l'avez exprimé des médicaments sont été
compressés vers le bas et dans d'autres
pays européens ils sont vendus plus cher
mais le marché
est sans doute aussi un des plus grands
d'Europe puisque il y a ce remboursement
par la Sécurité sociale qui assure à
l'industriel une diffusion de masse que
d'autres pays n'auront pas donc l'un
dans l'autre est-ce que cela ne
s'équilibre pas
vous avez évidemment raison on a
remplacé la politique du prix par une
politique des volumes
et c'est vrai qu'un si le marché
pharmaceutique français est intéressant
avec tous les effets pervers
induits dans un marché mondialisé dans
un marché de la européen dont l'un des
principes et la libre circulation des
marchandises effectivement
et
les
industriels se sont ainsi rattrapés sur
la dette
juste effectivement madame la ministre
par rapport à ce que vous avez dit au
niveau européen nous avons nous nous
sommes déplacés nous sommes allés à
Bruxelles et nous avons
auditionné les mains et les rats aussi
je veux doute voilà mais ce que nous
avons trouvé et je veux le dire lors de
cette audition comme nous l'avons dit
depuis le départ c'est une industrie
mondialisée
évidemment les mêmes les mêmes
politiques produisent les mêmes effets
donc chaque pays vit des pénuries des
ruptures de stock etc et
nous avons en tout cas trouvé au niveau
de nos interlocuteurs une volonté
qui
c'est exprimé en
nous affirmant en tout cas que il y
avait une volonté de créer au niveau
européen
une synergie et d'essayer de faire en
sorte que y compris quand on parle de
réindustrialisation ce serait
complètement absurde et je pense
vraiment que personne n'y pense enfin je
vous espérez que personne n'y pense que
ça ne se passe que sur le sol français
ce serait totalement ridicule et nous
avons trouvé une volonté exprimée
notamment au niveau de l'aimant de faire
en sorte qu'il y ait une coordination
européenne et que la relocalisation se
fasse en bonne intelligence alors c'est
tout un travail une fois que j'ai dit ça
j'ai rien réglé du tout mais une bonne
intelligence entre les différents pays
pour qu'au moins les productions
se rapprochent et que ça soit plus
facile au niveau de la distribution que
quand ça se passe à l'autre bout de la
planète et y compris d'ailleurs au
niveau écologique etc donc le sentiment
alors peut-être que je suis quelqu'un
d'optimiste certainement mais que les
crises que nous venons de vivre et qui
hélas
on n'est pas au bout de nos peines parce
que des crises il y en aura d'autres
j'ai quand même le sentiment qui est une
prise de conscience
plus globale et qui peut permettre
effectivement de trouver des solutions
partagées à la fois au niveau national
mais aussi au niveau européen alors
voilà donc c'est une petite porte ou qui
qui peut s'ouvrir sur
une fenêtre qui s'en trouve mais ça me
paraît intéressant par rapport à la
situation que que nous vivons et je ne
pense pas que on puisse trouver des
solutions en dehors de ce niveau
européen
je suis bien d'accord avec vous sur le
fait qu'il y a une volonté
d'harmonisation
et de réindustrialisation
toutefois la personne qu'il faudra
convaincre c'est Madame la Commissaire à
la concurrence
parce que
quand on est dans la première phase
je peux vous dire que quand on en est à
la
au stade d'opérationnel j'ai pu en
savourer toutes les difficultés dans la
défense de la propriété intellectuelle
de la propriétaire artistique comme
ministre de la Culture
au niveau de la du concept de la défense
des consommateurs
et de la libre
disposition de la concurrence on vient
tamponner tout ce que nous venons de
dire
première chose ensuite
la
l'Europe et les plurielle
les politiques industrielles au niveau
des grands pays
ça va
mais l'Europe c'est un pays une voix
vous savez j'ai présidé
le Conseil des Ministres en charge des
affaires sociales et sanitaires
j'ai présidé celui de la culture l'année
dernière mais
j'ai présidé au deuxième semestre 2008
j'avais imaginé
en 2008 de faire un exercice avec mes
collègues
exercices purement théorique
impliquant un scénario totalement
inimaginable que l'Europe était frappée
par une épidémie causée par un virus
respiratoire vous voyez que j'étais en
pleine folie
on m'a répliqué mes collègues tout cela
a été de la fantasmagorique ça
n'arriverait jamais
et qui donc il était inutile de mettre
en place des stratégies communes
et quand
l'épidémie de virus H1 est arrivé j'ai
tenté de faire que les achats de vaccins
et des substances utiles dans la gestion
de l'épidémie relève d'une politique
européenne
j'ai pas trouvé grand monde au bout du
téléphone et dans les conseils
ma collègue ministre polonaise m'a même
dit que les vaccins avaient autant
d'efficacité que l'eau distillée
alors
c'est bien là quel problème
c'est que les forces
[Musique]
centrifientes en Europe
et que pour mener ces politiques une
fois que nous en serons ça
d'opérationnel tout ça sera très
compliqué permettait à une vieille bête
de rappeler quelques souvenirs
la vieille bête vous salue mesdames
[Rires]
merci
madame la ministre pour ses échanges
pour la qualité de vos vocabulaire
jusqu'à la pourrie et donc
voilà pour rebondir sur la question
européenne puisque c'est bien que nous
terminons finalement cette audition sur
ce sujet la covid est quand même passée
par là la commande de vaccins en Europe
est passée par là le prix du coût du
vaccin et la gestion des stocks de façon
européenne est passée par là et donc il
semble et le paquet médicament vient
enfin de sortir au niveau européen et
donc il semblerait que la question de la
santé devient une question un tout petit
peu européenne en tout cas qui a une
prise de conscience que dans certaines
circonstances c'est un sujet important
et donc les pénuries probablement vont
jouer une partie de ce rôle je vous
remercie beaucoup